cette audition Mesdames et Messieurs mes
chers collègues après la Guyane nous
vous suivons nos travaux sur la
parentalité dans les outre-mer en commun
par nos deux délégations sénatoriales à
délégation au droit des femmes présidées
par Annick Billon et la délégation aux
outre-mer que présidé la présidente
Annick billon a dû s'absenter pour
participer à la séance publique où elle
défend des amendements et son excuse
auprès de vous outre les deux présidents
les deux autres corps rapporteurs de
cette étude sont victoires jasmin en
visioconférence ma collègue de
Guadeloupe et Elsa Charles qui est
absente aujourd'hui pour nous aider à
appréhender la situation particulière de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon nous
accueillons à présent pour la
collectivité territoriale Madame
Jacqueline André vice-présidente en
charge des solidarités et Madame Sonia
Borotra directrice du pôle développement
solidaire et enfin pour la Caisse de
Prévoyance Sociale madame sylvic kulch
directrice adjoint et Madame Aurore
Vignaud responsable de l'action sociale
en charge de la parentalité j'ai cru
apercevoir une troisième personne
personnes et je m'en excuse par avance
parce que je ne la reconnais pas à
distance
mesdames puisque cette table ronde est
essentiellement féminine et entièrement
féminine d'ailleurs vous avez été
destinataires d'une trame de questions
en fait qui nous permet
qui nous permet notamment au rapporteur
de pouvoir établir notre rapport ce que
je vous propose c'est d'abord un propos
liminaire que ce soit pour la
collectivité ou pour la Caisse de
Prévoyance Sociale vous pouvez aussi
passer au travers des différentes
questions qui vous ont été adressées de
toute façon ce que nous souhaitons bien
évidemment c'est pouvoir disposer de
votre part d'un support écrit ce qui
permet quand même de faciliter le
travail des rapporteurs et des
administrateurs qui travaillent à la
mise en forme et à la réflexion sur ce
rapport donc on peut se dire également
en audition des choses qu'on n'a pas
forcément écrit mais vous pouvez aussi
passer au travers des différents
éléments de réponse que vous avez déjà
élaboré donc ce je vous propose c'est de
donner la parole dans l'ordre que j'ai
évoqué d'abord la collectivité je vous
laisse le soin au sein de chaque
structure de vous répartir le temps de
parole donc la coopérativité vous
organisez et puis la Caisse de
Prévoyance Sociale vous organisez
également on dispose d'environ d'environ
une heure pour pouvoir échanger sur la
parentalité à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
je laisse peut-être la parole à
Jacqueline la vice-présidente chez
Jacqueline tu as la parole
merci cher Stéphane bonjour à toutes et
à tous donc la collectivité territoriale
en ce qui concerne le domaine social à
la fois les compétences d'un département
et d'une région
donc
en dessous de la parentalité on
travaille en collaboration avec la
Caisse de Prévoyance sociale qui a les
compétences CAF donc je laisserai tout à
l'heure donc à mes collègues de la
Caisse de Prévoyance Sociale le soin de
présenter ton travail qui est fait qui a
été fait ces dernières années en terme
d'action sociale famille et après je
laisserai aussi enfin voir avec Sonia
tout le travail qui est fait en termes
d'aide sociale à l'enfance et aussi
également pour au niveau de la maison
territoriale de l'autonomie sur
l'accompagnement des familles
qui ont des des enfants des jeunes en
situation de handicap et voir comment on
peut les accompagner puisque c'est pour
nous aussi un axe qui va être
prioritaire donc ce que je vous propose
c'est peut-être de passer le relais
enfin je sais pas si tu veux compléter
mes propos Sonia
la Caisse de Prévoyance Sociale est
vraiment un acteur majeur tant en termes
de prestations qui sont spécifiques et
aussi en termes de toutes vos réactions
sociales qui est bien développée donc la
CPS comme disait voilà mandrée Gerba en
fait l'ensemble des venge de la sécurité
sociale en métropole dans la branche
famille nous proposons à la population
des prestations légales qui sont proches
des prestations qui existent en
métropole on n'est pas à l'identique
complètement aujourd'hui
et on a développé une action sociale en
faveur des familles et particulièrement
depuis que depuis que on peut émerger au
Front national d'action sociale de la
Caisse nationale
donc le premier la première année on a
bénéfice en 2014 donc
c'est pour ça que mes collègues du
Service Action ça a été associée à
Madame Vignaud et Madame laral sont
présents aujourd'hui pourront du coup
parler de des actions développées au
bénéfice des familles de l'archipel
on peut peut-être pour avoir une trame
repartir si vous le souhaitez sur
exactement on peut passer au travers des
trois différents thèmes et je vous
laisse le soin de VOUS répartir le temps
de parole donc on peut on abordera
d'abord les spécificités familiales et
parentales de l'archipel si vous en avez
constaté les politiques familiales et
les prestations et enfin le soutien à la
parentalité
c'est que sur l'archipel l'organisation
familiale se rapproche quasiment
identique à ce qui se passe en métropole
et n'a absolument rien à voir avec ce
qui se passe par exemple à la Réunion ou
en Polynésie française donc on n'a pas
la problématique des grossesses précoces
c'est quelque chose que l'on a pas ici
il y a un lien parental et il y a encore
un lien familial qui se tisse mais qui a
tendance à se détendre quand même donc
il y a
je dirais une présence quand même des
familles des grands-parents dans
l'entourage des jeunes enfants qui
restent importants avec une vigilance
aussi à apporter parce qu'on a de plus
en plus de familles qui viennent de
l'extérieur donc qui n'ont pas cette
chance d'être accompagné par un par un
tissu familial
l'importance des familles monoparentales
je dirais que c'est la même chose qu'on
métropole il y a pas on est vraiment sur
les mêmes les mêmes organisations de là
à vous dire si c'est subi ou choisi
j'aurais plutôt tendance à vous dire que
je ne sais pas on n'a pas tu sais pas
mon vous qui êtes plus en contact avec
les familles comment vous pouvez je
pense que on peut le faire pour les voir
sous deux angles il y en a qui c'est un
choix voilà la relation de fonctionne
plus et il se sépare d'un commun accord
et d'autres ou c'est plutôt subi aussi
parce que par exemple peut-être pas
choisi cette situation
monoparentale donc je pense qu'on a un
peu les deux côtes figure oui ça dépend
vraiment de chaque situation de vie
apprenez en mesure de vous fournir des
chiffres sur les tomes matrimonial des
personnes qui touchent des prestations
de la branche famille je demandais une
extraction un autre service informatique
donc déjà en termes de profil si ça peut
vous éclairer un peu on a 20% en fait
des bénéficiaires qui sont soit en
situation de célibat divin de séparation
veuvage et 80% qui sont en situation
soit de concubinage mariage pas de soude
marital
donc ça vous donne une légitime un peu
vendredi
est-ce que vous avez des questions
particulières à nous poser sur ces
plages ce que je vous propose en termes
de méthodes c'est que vous passez au
travers du questionnaire de manière
transversaire et puis par la suite
les rapporteurs donc en l'occurrence
victoire jasmin qui est présente en
visioconférence et moi-même ou poseront
des questions si on estime qu'on a pas
couvert complètement le champ et ensuite
je laisserai la parole à mes collègues
sénateurs présents s'ils souhaitent vous
en poser également voilà donc on fait
donc il y a très opérationnel et très
très fluide pour que vous ayez plus
avoir le temps de parole maximum
donc sur la familiale et prestations de
la question suivante était quelle
structure s'en charge et politique
familiale et sociales à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et comment sont
fixés les objectifs et stratégies de ces
politiques donc là ça concerne nos
collègues de la CPS donc c'est
effectivement comme je disais tout à
l'heure c'est la CPS qui a toute la
partie compétence CAF tout à fait voilà
comment il y a la partie effectivement
prestation légale et prestations
australiales mais sur la partie
prestation légale en fait on a des
prestations
qui sont relativement similaires à celle
de la métropole sachant que on est en
phase d'évolution depuis 2007 pour un
rapprochement au plus près de ce qui se
fait au niveau du régime général
sur
la branche sur la partie prestation
extra légale je vais passer la parole à
Madame Gino qui va pouvoir vous éclairer
donc sur notre partie extra légal nous
avons tout un tas de d'aide financières
individuelles indépendamment des
situations que la famille peuvent vivre
donc nous avons tout ce qui est
isolement parental
accès éducatif budgétaires et de
financière exceptionnelle la survenue
d'une maladie humaine handicap chez
l'enfant ou chez un de ses parents donc
après voilà comme je le préciser au
début en s'inspire évidemment des
politiques des caisses nationales de
métropole tout en tenant compte de nos
spécificités locales et notre objectif
est de déployer une politique en matière
familiale qui rejoint vraiment c'est ces
deux choses
donc on a aussi toute notre partie
Action sociale famille par rapport aux
partenaires donc le financement de la
prestation de service unique auprès de
l'unique crèche de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon on a aussi la
prestation accueil de loisirs sans
hébergement auprès de l'unique centre
aéré de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon aussi
en octobre des subventions à différentes
associations par exemple on a
l'association des petits flocons qui ont
élaboré dernièrement une maison
d'assistante maternelle
en opère également nous en tant que
service d'action sociale un service de
médiation familiale
donc avec un partenaire de métropole
donc c'est une association de Rennes qui
se nomme espace médiation et qui vient à
raison de 7 6 à 7 missions sur
l'archipel mais qui peut aussi opérer à
distance via des rendez-vous ou des
séances en visioconférence on a un
service de conseiller individuel et
familial donc là les séances sont
également opérées par la médiatrice
familiale en charge
de réaliser des missions présentiel sur
l'archipel on a un service espace
rencontre par enfant
et on a aussi donc un relais d'assistant
maternelle par enfant qui va évoluer
courant 2023 en relais petite enfance
tel que cela a pu se passer sur le
territoire métropolitain donc voilà on a
vraiment un panel assez large finalement
sur notre axe famille entre les aides
financières individuelles à destination
des familles et de tout notre offre
partenariale je dirais sur tant le
versement de prestation de service que
l'accompagnement des acteurs de terrain
et des associations pour déployer notre
politique familiale sur l'architecture
voilà et au niveau des prestations
légales
la question de la spécificité locale est
aussi un argument qui a
prévalu quand il s'est agit des temps de
certaines prestations puisque faut
savoir qu'on a des particularités sur un
certain nombre de Varennes et ça c'est
lié aux spécificités de la vie sur le
territoire
il y a d'autres différences après si
vous voulez que je vous éclaire un peu
plus sur les différences de prestations
celles qui sont pas encore en place
celles qui vont être mises en place etc
vous me le dites et je peux aller entre
un peu plus en détail mais je ne veux
pas non plus vous voyez sous des
explications
ces explications techniques nous seront
utiles mais celle-là peuvent être
adressées par écrit je pense que là au
niveau au niveau d'audition on peut
rester effectivement dans les dans les
choses les plus accessibles pour nous
pour éviter de nous nous perd
effectivement aux éléments techniques
qui je ne doute pas sans maîtriser de
votre côté mais pas forcément du ventre
parce que par rapport à ce que disait
mes collègues de la CPS c'est qu'il y a
la CPAS à établi un schéma territorial
d'action sociale donc il y avait été
dressé il y a quelques années qui avait
été fait avec les partenaires donc il y
a eu tout un travail de partenariat qui
a été fait à ce moment-là et qui ont
ciblé vraiment des priorités et dans ce
que disait voir tout à l'heure le
conseil individuel c'est quelque chose
qui fonctionne très bien avec la
médiatrice familiale le conseil
individuel vous a été inspiré par ce que
font les Canadiens c'est à dire dans le
cas de la médiation familiale il faut
que les deux personnes soient d'accord
et c'est pas toujours facile alors que
dans le cas du conseil individuel c'est
une médiation c'est une c'est un conseil
qui permet à la personne de faire le
point sur la situation conflictuelle ou
la difficulté qui est rencontrée et
éventuellement d'amener l'autre personne
à la médiation familiale et je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui remporte
beaucoup de succès oui donc il y a aussi
ce qui s'est développé une médiation
familiale de plus en plus maintenant
avec les jeunes lycéens et aussi avec
les jeunes étudiants qui sont à
l'extérieur de archipel disons que les
précisera si nécessaire mais je pense
qu'il y a il y a eu tout un temps
d'adaptation c'est à dire c'était de la
laisser de la nouveauté sur un petit
territoire il faut que ça prenne que les
gens fassent confiance ou prestataire
c'est toujours des licornes de venir
livrer ses problématiques personnelles à
des tiers surtout sur une petite
population comme la nôtre mais je pense
qu'il y a effectivement le bouche à
oreille qui fonctionne beaucoup les
situations qui ont pu être résolues ou
en tout cas accompagné de manière
à faire évoluer favorablement ont permis
à d'autres personnes de connaître le
service et d'y faire appel et du coup on
est sorti de la vision simple séparation
d'un couple et on rentre dans des
problématiques familiales beaucoup plus
larges donc par exemple depuis deux ans
on a beaucoup développé la médiation
parents adolescents et c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne bien donc tant un
service de conseil individuel ou
familial ou voilà les familles sont
rencontrées dans un premier temps donc
les parents et ensuite les enfants et
après on essaye de rassembler tout le
monde dans l'objectif de renouer le
dialogue au sein de la cellule familiale
et de trouver des solutions alternatives
pour que les relations soient le plus
soit les plus saines possible donc oui
effectivement et puis c'est quelque
chose qui rentre de plus en plus dans
les mœurs de saint-pierre-et-miquelonner
on voit quand même qu'il y a une
certaine tendance en a moins honte de
faire appel à ce type de service et le
bouche à oreille vu qu'on est une petite
île fonctionne très très bien et du coup
la qualité du service rendu voilà ça
avait des gens sont très satisfaits et
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne
vraiment très bien
de ton côté Sonia enfin si vous avez
terminé maintenant je propose d'écouter
Sonia peut-être sur la partie sociale de
la collectivité et à eux
oui donc au niveau de la collectivité
effectivement notre action se situe
principalement au niveau du service
social de polyvalence et au niveau du
service de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
une particularité locale dont je voulais
vous faire part c'est le fait que
l'émission de PMI à Saint-Pierre sont
confiées au centre hospitalier donc nous
les exerçons pas c'est une partie au cas
les déclinée dans le code de la santé
publique donc pour nous notre action se
situe principalement donc au niveau de
l'ASE et du service social
on fait de la guidance parentale
évidemment avec les travailleurs sociaux
que nous avons dans nos services
pardon et puis nous intervenons
également au niveau de la maison
territoriale de l'autonomie au niveau
donc du handicap je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs ça fait partie des besoins
repérés à savoir de pouvoir intensifier
cette cette ce soutien par cette
guidance en faveur des parents d'enfants
en situation de handicap qui sont
parfois aujourd'hui un peu
malmené et ont besoin en tout cas de
d'un soutien renforcé et de répit
voilà ce que je voulais juste préciser
on pense que l'on continue sur
la partie la cinquième question sur le
montant global des différentes
prestations sociales versées aux
familles et l'appart représente ses
ressources dans les familles de
l'archipel est-ce que ça fait partie des
éléments que vous pourriez envoyer
Sylvie ou pas oui je pourrais les
envoyer oui voilà donc voilà j'ai les
chutes activités 2021 mais d'une année
sur l'autre sa relation ça bouge peu à
on a pour vous donner les je vous donne
le juste de trois chiffres et je vous
donnerai les donner pour 2021 et 2022 en
détail par par mail on a 417 familles
qui bénéficiaient des prestations
familiales les allocations familiales
pour un million six de dépenses en 2021
donc
on a son cas familles qui ont touché
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
150 bénéficiaires d'allocations de base
de la page etc enfin je vous donnerai
tout les chiffres en détails de rentrer
dans le
point de détail
prestations légales et en extra légal
sur 2022 on a 130 000 euros de
financement de prestations de services
ou de l'individu voilà
donc idem pour la 6e question
sur
les prestations enfin la différence des
prestations par rapport à la métropole
je pense que là bon vous ferez le point
sur tout ce qui est en train d'être mis
en place donc on vous enverra enfin à la
CPAS voilà
fait son sujet
de mon un peu plus précise pour ou sinon
on va s'y attend on va partir de cette
demande de simple à savoir que juste
spécifiquement que avec la elle était 16
2023 il y a de nouvelles prestations qui
vont être mises en place dans le courant
de l'année qui sont la location
journalière de précédent et l'allocation
journalière
présentée
mais écoutez si vous en êtes d'accord je
vous propose qu'on continue sur
la partie vraiment soutien à la
parentalité avec la question 7 sur quels
sont les besoins que l'on identifie en
matière soutient la parentalité
faut-il mettre en place une éducation en
apparentalité et à quel moment selon
quel modalité doit-on cibler
spécifiquesment les parents d'enfants en
situation de décrochage scolaire ou de
délinquance on va cadre judiciaire ou
privilégiez-vous une approche globale
alors je vais me permettre de commencer
les besoins à identifier en matière de
soutien la parentalité
oui il faut les mettre en place
effectivement du soutien de la
parentalité je pense dès le plus jeune
âge avec donc on doit retravailler
ensemble entre nous mais on souhaiterait
il n'y a pas ici encore de schémas de
départemental de service aux familles
donc ce serait quelque chose qui serait
avoir avec l'État pour que vraiment que
qu'on reprenne on a beaucoup
d'indicateurs quand même et qu'on puisse
cibler ensemble
les actions prioritaires à mettre en
place et que chacun puisse y prendre sa
place
on est influencé je verrai par les
approches noires américaines et dans
votre question
qui est est-ce qu'on approche en droit
privilégiée une approche globale je vous
dirai vraiment oui dans un premier temps
en tout cas tous les parents de
donneraient pouvoir bénéficier du
soutien à la parentalité on sait qu'en
métropole il y a eu les 1000 premiers
jours de l'enfant donc un accompagnement
dès l'annonce de la grossesse qui
pourrait tout à fait être mis en place
sur l'archipel étant donné nos petits
effectifs donc et un accompagnement sur
les trois les trois premières années
les trois premières années du de
l'enfant par la suite on est en
réflexion avec le président sur un
projet éducatif du territoire
qui pourrait permettre aussi de cibler
un accompagnement à la fois des jeunes
aussi des parents dans leur parentalité
avec les établissements scolaires avec
le péri et l'extrascolaire également
on souhaite aussi travailler et on en a
échangé avec l'Éducation nationale
dernièrement parce qu'on a eu la vis
d'un inspecteur général sur le
développement des conséquences des
compétences pardon psychosociales des
jeunes des enfants des tout-petits et
des jeunes et en même temps sur le
développement des compétences
psychosociales des parents parce que
pour nous les devons ensemble
sur alors moi je j'insiste aussi sur la
conciliation vie familiale vie
professionnelle parce qu'on sait que
c'est
particulièrement important donc on
manque un peu de la crèche et prise
d'assaut ici en manque de de nounou
agréer donc c'est quelque chose pour
lequel on essaie qu'on essaie de
développer et dans la conciliation du
familiale vie professionnelle il y a un
nouveau besoin qui se fait sentir il
faut voir sur l'archipel on n'a pas de
cantine scolaire
et que ça pose quand même quelques
difficultés aux familles surtout par
exemple on a du maintien à domicile qui
se développe de plus en plus pour les
personnes âgées personne en situation de
handicap et ce sont quand même des
horaires qui sont atypiques comme dans
certains métiers et c'est d'essayer de
réfléchir à mieux accompagner et comment
on peut trouver des solutions aux
familles parce que pour l'instant les
nounous agréés
à 17h30 le soir donc pour les horaires
atypiques et pour le la période entre
midi et 13h30 pour les parents qui ont
des contraintes horaires ça reste
compliqué
sur
le décrochage scolaire ou la délinquance
là je laisserai peut-être la partie à
Sonia sachant que bon juste dire que les
familles on les connaît on est en train
de travailler avec l'Éducation nationale
sur les informations préoccupantes qui
nous sont donnés beaucoup trop
tardivement on a eu jusqu'à 90
demi-journée d'absence avoir d'avoir
avant d'avoir l'information préoccupante
ou alors elle nous arrive au mois de
juin et à un moment donné on nous
travaille en sociaux ne peuvent plus
intervenir ou c'est difficile
d'intervenir auprès des familles donc là
on a eu un lien avec la conseillère
technique
sociale du rectorat de
Caen
et les choses sont en train de se mettre
en place en tout cas pour pouvoir mieux
travailler avec l'Éducation nationale et
faire en sorte que ces informations
soient vraiment beaucoup plus précoces
nos travailleurs sociaux je vais te
laisser la parole Sonia sur le travail
des l'accompagnement des familles en
termes d'azo et de travailleurs sociaux
pour revenir sur l'absentéisme le
décrochage c'est vrai que on manque
aujourd'hui cruellement de données
puisque
nous ces données ne sont pas remontées
de l'absentéisme massif qui nous
interroge donc on a saisi effectivement
la rectrice de Normandie pour qu'on
puisse travailler ensemble sur ce sujet
important
et qu'en plus décliner les protocoles
nationaux et notamment la plateforme de
lutte contre le décrochage qui m'envoie
n'est pas effective ici donc on a engagé
ce travail avec l'Éducation nationale
récemment et puis bon sur pourtant la
prévention de la délinquance c'est vrai
que le sujet n'est pas majeur quand même
dans l'archipel il y a un peu de
délinquance des mineurs mais quand même
très peu
donc c'est pas aujourd'hui franchement
une problématique sur le territoire mais
néanmoins le décrochage d'entreprise si
et le fait que le l'éducation nationale
ne possède pas de service social en
faveur des familles et aujourd'hui un
frein à la bonne prise de ces situations
d'absentéisme et à l'information des
parents on voit bien que la formation
sur l'obligation scolaire n'est pas tout
à fait fait quoi donc il y a sûrement
quelque chose à développer à ce niveau
là
complètement
on a dans les échanges qu'on a eu aussi
avec la conseillère technique de la
maîtrise de camp il y avait la demande
de
décliner localement la plateforme phare
qui est la plateforme sur la
l'accompagnement
comme on appelle ça de
harcèlement voilà du harcèlement parce
qu'il y a on rencontre et les parents
revient vers nous pour nous le dénoncer
sur l'archipel quand on commence à venir
à l'école on suit à peu près la même
place d'âge sous le temps il y a des
phénomènes de harcèlement qui sont pas
pris en charge et qui font qui ont pour
des bonnes conséquences dans la profonde
à l'être mais aussi des décrochages et
quand on échange avec les
médecins ont fait et même le juge aux
affaires familiales il trouve qu'il y a
ici beaucoup de certificats pour phobie
scolaire
donc et on sait qu'on a répété ou le
contrat d'expilerait quelques jeunes
parce qu'en fait il s'en sort enfin
localement l'expérience qu'ils ont vécu
était assez était tellement difficile
que la solution était de partir à
l'extérieur donc c'est
bon vous êtes revenus
[Musique]
c'est bon
donc par rapport à cela vous nous
entendez oui
c'est bon oui c'est bon
par rapport aux problèmes de phobie
scolaire et de harcèlement
voilà le médecin
du rectorat de Caen à contacter les
médecins localement pour essayer de
comprendre un peu le ce phénomène et
là il y a tout un accompagnement une
déclinaison de la plateforme phare qui a
donné très bons résultats en métropole
qui va se mettre en place sur l'archipel
et pour nous aussi avec un
accompagnement des parents parce que
c'est aussi
c'est aussi des parents qui nous ont
sollicité par rapport à ces difficultés
[Musique]
je sais pas si tu veux compléter Sonia
ou si c'est bon pour toi ou si de ton
côté Marie
maintenant oui
pour notre part donc oui effectivement
il y a de toute manière des besoins
d'accompagnement à la parentalité
mettre en place une éducation à la
parentalité moi je suis plutôt vous avez
bien
accompagnement éducation à la
parentalité en évitant principalement de
cibler les familles qui auraient des
dans les enfants et des soucis de
délinquance ou parce que c'est toujours
en lien avec un petit test de Lille en
identifie vite qui a fait des bêtises et
pourquoi il a été jugé ou autre donc
l'idée n'est pas de les stigmatiser mais
bien de notre idée d'avoir un cadre
général et après de travailler de
manière un petit peu plus individuelle
avec ce type de situation qui relèverait
davantage de la délinquance ou d'un
autre cadre donc on est tout à fait en
face sur le fait de développer une
approche globale à quel moment et selon
quel modalité je pense que
à tous les moments de la vie d'une
famille donc c'est la mission de Marie
donc je vais la laisser un petit peu
développer sur la question mais c'est de
pouvoir en fait
construire une boîte à outils et à
l'intérieur de cette boîte à outils que
chaque parent puisse utiliser l'outil ou
le ou les outils qui lui convient le
mieux dépendamment de la situation
traversée la difficulté rencontrée ou
peut-être même juste du questionnement
des fois on n'est pas sur forcément une
problématique particulière on est aussi
sur un questionnement pour
être en phase avec nos valeurs de
parentalité etc etc donc je vais laisser
la parole aussi à ma collègue qui est en
charge de ce volet là au sein de mon
service merci oui vous avez toutes deux
bien résumer mesdames en effet leur
particularité locale et je pense qu'ici
c'est certain que c'est à travailler le
soutien la parentalité c'est quelque
chose d'assez nouveau
voilà la guidance parentale ça ça y
vient de plus en plus mais c'est certain
qu'aujourd'hui on va dire ce qui peut
basique sur la métropole qui peut se
faire comme un café des parents qui peut
avoir lieu voilà un atelier XY où on
peut venir avec son enfant ou simplement
en tant que jeune parents c'est vrai que
sur l'archipel il y a pas encore tout ça
et je pense que ça c'est certain que ça
toute sa place et c'est à mettre en
place il y a une vraie demande et tant
pour les parents que pour les
professionnels aussi de la petite
enfance sur l'archipel je pense que
c'est important de rassembler on a des
professionnels qui sont prêts à venir
sur des lieux d'échange d'écoute de
partage et voilà les mentalités évoluent
ça rentre dans les mœurs c'est certain
que voilà c'est difficile c'est une
particularité locale on vient on
s'assoit on connaît ou en identifiant en
tout cas la personne qui est à côté de
nous et je pense que voilà ça c'était un
frein il y a quelques années aujourd'hui
on vient s'inspirer de ce qui fonctionne
bien ailleurs il faut pas oublier que
notre population elle a évolué aussi
nous sommes voilà 50 même un peu plus de
50% la population qui est métropolitaine
donc je pense que c'est un réel atout
pour la parentalité
c'est une force d'avoir ces gens qui
viennent de l'extérieur avec un regard
nouveau et surtout qui connaissent voilà
les ateliers les événements ils vont
venir et briser un petit peu là ce tabou
qu'on aurait à venir dire voilà parfois
c'est pas saisir des professionnels dans
de l'urgence elle t'a fait des parents
c'est aussi un moment où on vient
échanger on vient écouter on vient
prendre voilà un peu la boîte à outils
comme disait ma collègue et ça ça manque
sur l'archipel donc je pense je rejoins
une éducation à la parentalité non on
est dans l'accompagnement et vraiment
dans une approche globale en incluant
les professionnels qui a sur archival
quoi
merci
moi je voulais juste compléter en disant
qu'on a
on repère aussi des forces chez les
parents et donc on a une approche qui
n'est pas déficitaire mais une approche
pour se dire que on part des forces des
parents pour mieux les accompagner et
donc tous ces lieux de rencontre qui
sont en train de se mettre en place ce
sont aussi des lieux d'échange et des
lieux de mixité sociale où les familles
de l'archipel ou des familles qui
viennent de l'extérieur et quel que soit
le milieu social peuvent aussi se
rencontrer et c'est pour nous quelque
chose
vraiment de très important donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu quelques cafés des
parents qui se sont qui ont vu le jour
là et avec des réponses intéressantes et
puis voilà les gens ont envie de se
rencontrer et se baser sur la
psychologie positive et toujours aussi
quelque chose qui permet d'attirer et le
fait aussi de vouloir attirer tous les
parents
ça permet vraiment cet échange et on
sait aussi que c'est très efficace quand
les parents peuvent échanger entre eux
et que c'est pas une institution ou un
professionnels mais voilà coller les
parents puissent faire part de leur
expérience et pouvoir se retrouver
et c'est certain que oui je pense que la
petite enfance par exemple quelque chose
qui se met en place en métropole c'est
la dixième édition cette année j'ai pas
pu la relier mais l'année prochaine
c'est certain c'est la Semaine Nationale
et la petite enfance on voit qu'à
travers toute la métropole et outre-mer
ça prend bien et en fait c'est ce qui
est sympa de voir c'est que c'est la
diversité des intervenants qui vont
mettre des actions en place à travers
cette semaine là en fait comment le
professionnel le parent s'approprie par
exemple une semaine en France et sur
l'archipel c'est vrai que c'est des
choses qu'on mettait pas en place peu en
avant la journée aussi des assistantes
maternelles voilà c'est assez récent sur
l'archipel depuis 2016-2017 on parle
aujourd'hui d'assistante maternelle
sous son petit nom de nous mais voilà ça
y est c'est rentré un peu dans les mœurs
aussi avec la main comme disait comme
disait ma collègue et je pense que voilà
ça aussi les sont demandeurs
d'événements pour du coût participer
avec leurs enfants comment est-ce que
sur du temps personnel du coup on peut
voilà avoir des événements de famille et
on a tendance à faire venir beaucoup
d'intervenants sur l'archipel c'est en
effet c'est très bien dans un besoin
mais il y a aussi des intervenants il y
a une vraie richesse sur l'île et une
semaine à petite enfance à mettre en
place c'est du travail mais en un des
intervenants de qualité sur l'archipel
je pense que voilà c'est aussi un
travail de notre côté ça fait partie de
mes missions et pour 2024 voilà je pense
qu'il y a un pas à avancer et c'est des
erreurs comme ça qui je pense peut
rassembler aussi ce soir et tout ça
c'est aussi en droit King de la mise en
place du complément libre choix du mode
de garde en 2016 parce que c'est pas
disponible dans l'archipel avant
donc
effectivement cette démarche
d'accompagnement des familles et des
professionnels à découler au niveau du
service
là pour continuer sur
les structures institutionnelles ou
associatives qui mettent aujourd'hui en
place des actions en matière de soutien
et la parentalité il y a une nouvelle
association qui s'est créée qui est
l'association Lila qui a appelé un an
d'existence je pense qui est intéressant
parce qu'en fait elle regroupe des
professionnels de santé psychologue
ostéopathe
kinés médecins
diététicienne et donc il y a aussi des
cafés qui se mettent en place avec avec
les parents donc je pense que là ça
fonctionne bien aussi je sais pas si tu
es en contact avec eux enfin moi j'avais
échangé un peu avec eux je pense qu'il y
a une belle dynamique aussi qui s'est
qui s'est enclenché de ce côté là donc
pour nous c'est vraiment aussi des
relais un relais intéressant
moi je voudrais juste revenir sur les
besoins et je sais pas si Sonia si tu
m'entends mais si tu peux parler un peu
des besoins spécifiques en a repéré sur
les familles qui ont des enfants en
situation de handicap en termes
d'accompagnement
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
effectivement j'étais en avance sur
ce besoin repérer à la fois
le schéma de l'autonomie et puis le
projet territorial l'enfance jeunesse
qui avait ce besoin de soutien à la
parentalité pour les parents en
situation de handicap donc autant dans
le volet éducatif que que dans le dans
le répit c'est-à-dire que par exemple il
n'y a pas de temps de vacances adaptées
et il y a pas de moments où les parents
peuvent vraiment souffler quand ils en
ont besoin donc il y aurait
éventuellement ce que le développement
de forme de répit qui serait intéressant
et puis
une forme de aussi de soutien surtout à
un mi-clan où on parle très peu de
handicap ou c'est encore quelque chose
qui est qui est tue qui est tabou et on
aimerait pouvoir vraiment accompagner
ses parents dans dans l'acceptation du
handicap et puis
le fait de pouvoir aussi solliciter les
aides et
avoir que les enfants aient accès à
leurs droits puisque aujourd'hui il y a
très très peu d'enfants en situation de
handicap repérer sur miclant alors que
bon il y a pas de raison que Lille y
échappe mais par exemple on a pas de
projet de de scolarisation pour pour
miclon ou très très peu et donc ça nous
interroge et donc il y aurait sans doute
un axe à développer là donc sur sur ces
questions de parentalité en lien avec le
handicap
un des axes que je pense aussi qu'on a
qu'on devrait être privilégié avec les
familles c'est l'accompagnement à
l'autonomie c'est aussi on s'inspire
aussi de ce que font de ce qui se passe
du côté Canada il y a trois axes qui
sont priorisés il y a la compétence
repérait la compétence chez les hommes
le sentiment d'appartenance appartenir à
sa communauté mais aussi l'autonomie et
on sait que sur l'archipel on vit quand
même dans un cocon et que
les jeunes ont besoin de partir ils sont
obligés de partir assez dentalement et
du jour au lendemain sans confrontés à
une autonomie assez brutale qui partent
au Canada ou en métropole donc il y a
aussi ça fait partie des choses que l'on
a repéré c'est comment accompagner les
parents pour rendre le jeune autonome le
plus laid le plus jeune âge et dans ce
contexte il y a une nouvelle association
qui vient de se créer qui s'appelle
l'association agep 9 7 5 qui est une
association à éducation populaire qui
justement met en situation les jeunes
pour qu'ils puissent construire leur
projet
par deux c'est à eux de les monter et on
ne sent plus à subir je dirais à être
consommateur de ce que les adultes ou
les différentes collectivités peuvent
leur proposer mais c'est simplement eux
qui décident qui font leur choix qui
montrent leurs projets financièrement
c'est les ouvrir aussi le plus le plus
possible sur sur l'extérieur par
l'intermédiaire des chantiers jeunesse
donc cette association vient d'ouvrir et
où là les jeunes ont l'air d'être de
très bien se l'approprier donc c'est
tout un travail qui va nous permettre
aussi de travailler sur l'autonomie du
jeûne avec avec les familles donc pour
nous c'était aussi important de le
signaler que
si jamais on va construire notre projet
éducatif du territoire on en a échangé
l'éducation nationale ce sera
probablement un axe fort rendre le jeune
autonome le plus vite possible et de
travailler que la famille afin de
compléter tes propos d'ailleurs avec le
service jeunesse de la collectivité il y
a une belle collaboration qui est en
train de naître entre service d'action
sociale de la CPS
de la collectivité territoriale sur
comment on peut développer une approche
globale territoriale pour accompagner au
mieux nos jeunes donc tant sur le choix
de partir pour suivre ses études à
l'extérieur d'archipel mais aussi pour
ceux qui ont des choix de vie un peu
différents et qui souhaitent aller plus
sur l'apprentissage ou rentrer
directement sur le marché du travail
c'est comment on peut les aider à
identifier leurs compétences ce qu'on
appelle nous compétences psychosociales
et les différentes personnes reçoivent
autour d'eux qu'il serait capable de
mobiliser pour justement leur donner
toutes les clés pour l'autonomie dont
ils ont besoin pour démarrer leur vie
le plus facilement possible en tout cas
c'est quand même un beau projet qui vont
être entre les deux institutions et
vraiment pour avoir une visée
territoriale d'accompagnement de nos
jeunes
sur notre territoire en fait oui c'est
très bien ce que dit aurores parce que
ça nous permet aussi d'accompagner il y
a un travail par alternance qui commence
à développer son archipel et pour les
jeunes qui étaient soit en rupture
scolaire ou en difficulté ça nous permet
ça permet aussi de leur proposer une
trajectoire professionnelle
en lien avec la kassima et il y a eu les
limites de l'apprentissage où il y avait
c'était très intéressant parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de jeunes mais aussi
beaucoup de parents et ça a permis
justement avec
vous étiez aussi je pense
des étudiants voilà et donc ça a permis
finalement de aux jeunes de de et avec
le service de la collectivité le service
jeunesse de la collectivité de pouvoir
avec les parents discuter des futurs
métiers de ce qui est ce qui est le
mieux adapté aux jeunes et on a vu là
aussi que l'accompagnement des parents
sur
le l'apprentissage était très
intéressant et très porteur pour nos
jeunes et même sur l'accompagnement au
départ et l'accompagnement au départ si
tu peux en dire un mot
au départ donc ça aussi c'est un projet
qui est né il y a deux trois ans c'est
on organise un forum des étudiants donc
là c'est la collectivité territoriale
c'est mon pilote où ce projet là est à
l'intérieur on a beaucoup de partenaires
qui viennent se gripper comme le CIO les
mutuelles pour l'emploi on a vraiment
une diversité les acteurs du territoire
pour accompagner au mieux nos jeunes et
depuis cette année
enfin un certain nombre d'années qu'on
remarque que effectivement il peut avoir
une certaine angoisse sur auprès des
jeunes mais surtout aussi auprès des
parents donc on va développer notre
accompagnement à notre parentalité sur
comment on peut
faciliter ce départ du petit nid
familial de nos jeunes qui partent
parfois assimile kilomètres pour pouvoir
suivre leurs études parce que tant il
faut préparer nos jeunes mais il faut
aussi préparer des parents pour que ça
se passe au mieux donc c'est aussi notre
objectif qu'on continuera de développer
sur les prochaines années c'est d'avoir
des actions un peu phares et à
destination de des parents des des
grands enfants quoi si je peux dire
sur le dernier point sur les liens des
partenariats avec des fédérations
nationales là je pense que vous avez
l'école des parents des éducateurs nous
sommes alors nous déjà on a la l'état
des rangs et puis donc à la Fédération
nationale de la médiation familiale et
des espaces familiaux donc la fenêtre
et puis ce qui est aussi très chouette
c'est que notre collaboration avec
espace médiation de Rennes sur notre
service de médiation familiale le
directeur d'espace médiation fait partie
du conseil d'administration de la finale
donc Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon à la
chance d'être présenté sur différentes
strates au niveau de la phénomène et du
coup bon bah espace médiation est
intervenu principalement sur l'archipel
pour déployer des missions de médiation
familiale et de conseils individuels ou
familial mais du coup ce qu'on avait
déployé sur notre archipel les a
inspirés et eux ont développé davantage
aussi leur champ d'activité sur
l'accompagnement à la parentalité et ils
ont obtenu l'année dernière un agrément
sur fois des parents et des éducateurs
donc c'est un peu voilà on se sert en
visualise nos services et nos approches
qui sert à tout le monde et
effectivement
le fait d'être présenté dans le conseil
d'administration de la phénomènes vous
permet aussi autant d'avoir une
représentation de notre territoire mais
d'avoir accès à tout un tas
d'informations de formation quand notre
personnel qui sont accrédités et qui
garantissent une qualité de service et
pourquoi pas un jour aussi nous devenir
école des parents et des éducateurs
internes sur l'archipel voilà dans la
même dans le même état d'esprit comme on
est un territoire isolé on cherche à se
rapprocher effectivement de partenaires
sur un métropole et la caisse a des
contraintes partenariats avec leur
centre des caisses de Rennes et là
on peut là je devrais rencontrer du coup
une représentante de la CAF de Rennes et
un
RP de Rennes pour justement permettre
aussi qu'il y ait qu'il y ait des
échanges avec des services qui existent
déjà en métropole et qui peuvent nous
apporter la plus-value de leur
expérience de leur savoir-faire pour
nous permettre de développer des projets
qui soient les plus performants possible
de ton côté Sonia est-ce que tu
souhaites compléter par quelque chose en
particulier
moi je voudrais juste dire en conclusion
peut-être que je pense qu'on a besoin de
renforcer la coordination entre nos
actions et entre les différents acteurs
de définir une politique pour notre
territoire parce qu'on voit qu'il y a
beaucoup d'actions mais elles
apparaissent peut-être isolé ou pas très
bien coordonnées on a besoin quand même
d'acteurs associatifs qui sont
globalement assez peu nombreux en dehors
de l'association que vous avez cité tout
à l'heure mais on voit bien que
aujourd'hui le soutien la parentalité
repose essentiellement sur la sur la CPS
et la connectivité territoriale
donc je pense qu'il y aurait quand même
une action à renforcer au niveau des au
niveau associatif ceci dit quand même la
difficulté à recruter enfin entre
guillemets au niveau associatif il y a
quand même un désengagement très net
associations dans ce secteur pas dans
d'autres secteurs comme le sport ou
autre ça ça fonctionne bien mais c'est
vrai que c'est vrai le domaine social et
médico-social c'est nettement plus
difficile de mots société donc je pense
qu'on a besoin de renforcer notre action
collective dans ce domaine voilà bon par
le biais d'un schéma peut-être mais en
tout cas de coordonnées
en place récemment les conditions
territoriales globales donc c'est un
sujet sur lequel on va se pencher il
faut échanger avec la Caisse nationale
sous peu et c'est un sujet sur lequel je
pense on reviendra sûrement vers la
collectivité parce que ce que
effectivement à l'outil intéressant pour
permettre de donner un sens
qui sont menées et à ce qui parle pour
tout ce qui parle à tous en fait tout le
monde voilà ça ce qui se fait sur chez
toi que les lisibilité pour les acteurs
comme pour la population au final est-ce
que vous souhaitez compléter avant qu'on
passe aux questions peut-être de
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
c'est bon pour vous de votre de ton côté
c'est fin est-ce que vous avez vous
souhaitez compléter par des questions je
vais très égoïste je vais commencer par
moi parce qu'en réalité le dernier point
que vous avez évoqué c'est le point que
j'allais soulever parce que j'ai en tête
en tête le périmètre du schéma d'action
sociale et familles qu'on a mis en place
ensemble entre la CPS collectivité les
mairies en particulier donc les CCAS et
la question que je me posais justement
puisqu'on a eu ce sujet là avec nos
collègues de la Guyane tout à l'heure
sur le le la difficulté de coordonner
l'ensemble des acteurs sur leur
territoire j'ai cité en exemple le
schéma que qui a été mis en place à un
moment donné sur le territoire à
saint-pierre-et-temps et la question que
j'avais c'est est-ce que ce schéma
vocation finalement
à être élargi justement par rapport à ce
que Sylvie vient de dire sur les
conventions globales que la que la CNAV
c'est ça si j'ai bien compris mais au
niveau voilà au niveau national ou
est-ce que ce schéma lui va perdurer de
son côté avec un nouveau schéma plus
global avec l'ensemble des acteurs voilà
c'était juste une question pratique ou
pratique et opérationnelle strictement
alors oui c'est vrai que dans ce schéma
il existe depuis on a commencé en 2010
je crois avec les enquêtes 2019
et compléter en 2013 donc c'est vrai que
à un moment donné avec les différents
changements politiques peut-être qu'on a
perdu un peu de dynamique sur ce
point-là donc nous avec la collectivité
à l'époque donc en 2018 en s'était mis
d'accord parce que c'est vrai que
c'était un schéma qui couvrait la petite
enfance l'enfance la jeunesse la
parentalité l'accompagnement au départ
en fait il était très très vaste et
c'était un peu compliqué au fur et à
mesure des années d'arriver à coordonner
tout ça donc en 2018 on s'est mis
d'accord avec la collectivité
territoriale pour nous élaborer deux
diagnostics un prix en charge par la
caisse de prévoyance sociale sur
vraiment la petite enfance donc les 0,8
ans donc tout ce qui concerne l'accueil
des enfants les structures les
établissements d'accueil du jeune enfant
la parentalité etc et la collectivité a
pris en charge la coordination
tout ça évidemment en partenariat mais
au niveau du pilotage sur le projet
territorial en France jeunesse qui l'a
ciblé plus les 9 30 ans
et du coup
et ben ces deux diagnostics sont un
point d'étape où on se voilà pour savoir
où on est rendu et du coup c'est vrai
que l'outil de la convention
territoriale globale donc il est pas de
refaire un schéma mais vraiment
d'utiliser cet outil là parce que on se
rend compte qu'il y a énormément de
choses qui sont déjà faites sur notre
territoire mais peut-être manque un peu
de vision beaucoup de coordination etc
et du coup on aimerait vraiment utiliser
la convention territoriale globale pour
redynamiser ces approches de politique
sociale et familiale et vraiment
redispacer le pilotage de toutes ces
actions là mais effectivement ça repose
énormément sur les épaules de la CBS et
de la collectivité territoriale puisque
c'est une particularité sur notre
archipel on peut pas vraiment dire que
les mairies sont très très investis sur
ces champs là alors après c'est
peut-être historique voilà ils ont déjà
beaucoup de choses à gérer
ne jette pas du tout la balle au mairies
c'est juste un
constater connaître je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup encore de travail politique et
stratégique à entamer on espère que
voilà là c'était j'ai pourra nous aider
donc et il faut reprendre les rencontres
partenariats etc pour voir parce que
tout ce qui était
prôné dans le cadre du schéma
territorial des services publics a été
réalisé finalement aujourd'hui c'est
comment en optimise les sources de
financement comment les optimise auprès
des structures auprès des politiques
qu'on déploé de la stratégie sur notre
territoire et voilà on a beaucoup
d'espoir sur la convention territoriale
globale puisque les retours qu'on
obtient du National sont très très
positifs donc on se dit que voilà et
puis on aimerait aussi que la CNAS
vienne faire une petite mission parce
qu'ils sont venus en 2012 pour qu'on
puisse échanger ensemble et puis voir
les perspectives d'évolution tout à fait
pour compléter aussi ce que ce que dit
Aurore c'est vrai que
à la fois sur le schéma petite enfance
c'est tout le projet jeunesse on s'est
rendu compte aussi en tout cas pour la
partie jeunesse que c'était important en
acier des actions pour les jeunes mais
c'est important aussi de faire avec les
parents c'est à dire que le parent c'est
parents du jeune et de pas se concentrer
que sur les besoins du jeûne mais les
besoins de parents aussi et de ne pas le
je dirais de le conforter dans son rôle
d'éducateur et c'est aussi vers ça qu'on
va c'est de se dire on doit tourner vers
les besoins des parents à la fois en
termes de d'organisation
conciliation vie familiale et vie
professionnelle mais aussi en tant que
parents en tant qu'éducateur comment
mieux les accompagner et bien s'il y a
leurs besoins et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on a besoin de compléter il me semble
encore encore de questions de mon côté
la première c'est est-ce qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui des obstacles juridiques
légaux qui empêche certaines prestations
de l'Hexagone d'être appliqué à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon concernant la
famille ça c'est la première question
puisque je le dis pour mes collègues et
ceux qui nous suivent c'est qu'à
Saint-Pierre on a un régime social qui
est différent de celui de l'Hexagone ce
qui peut expliquer donc dans certaines
prestations n'ont pas été rendu applica
donc je pose cette question et puis la
deuxième vous vous parlez des acteurs
qui sont impliqués donc je les ai en
tête puisqu'ils sont en face de nous en
l'occurrence la CPS et la collectivité
j'aimerais savoir au niveau de l'État si
vous avez le sentiment que sur ce
territoire il y a une dynamique ou une
réflexion alors que visiblement il y a
des crédits de l'État sur certains
lignes qui existent et qui ne semblent
pas forcément être mobilisés à l'heure
actuelle ça faisait partie des questions
ça faisait partie des questions aussi
qu'on a posé au ministère de l'Outre-mer
parce qu'en réalité il peut y avoir des
appels à progénationaux dont des
opérateurs locaux n'ont pas forcément
accès donc la question c'est est-ce que
vous sentez aussi une impulsion de
l'État ou est-ce que l'État est plutôt
observateur et c'est pas une critique
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'objectif
que je que je demande là
[Musique]
à un moment donné ils sont appliqués
comme je disais tout à l'heure il y a de
nouvelles prestations qui nous sont
étendues depuis la FSS si on attend
d'écrire d'application
c'est la location journalière
prochainement une allocation journalière
présence parentale on a des prestations
qui sont étendues avec des
particularités si je prends l'exemple
par exemple de la BPF on a mis la VPS
c'est première ni la BPF métropole on a
un statut hybride
[Musique]
on a des
on a des spécificités mais qui sont de
plus en plus
qui diminue de plus en plus on a des
particularités on n'a pas la prime de
déménagement qui a été étendue les Alf
et Alf ont été étendues en 2022 mais pas
la réelle
donc voilà le pré à la migration de
l'habitat n'existe pas non plus chez
nous et
pour l'instant mais on a des aides
là comment on a pas non plus
et l'aide de la complémentaire santé
qui est fiancé voilà la complémentaire
santé solidaire qui est versée sous
conditions non ressources
donc chez nous on n'est pas en place non
plus mais voilà
grosso modo on est vraiment sur
de plus en plus au plus près de ce qui
surnation nationale les difficultés
qu'on rencontre cependant c'est qu'on a
des dispositifs qui nous sont étendus et
qui ne concernent que quelques
situations et c'est une grosse
difficulté pour la CPS parce qu'on a pas
les outils nationaux on a
et quand on a des
différences réglementaires quelquefois
des spécificités on est en difficulté
pour pouvoir former nos personnels parce
qu'on peut pas les former sur des outils
qu'on a peur
on est toujours obligé les formateurs de
métropole sont sur les règles de
métropole mais comme on a souvent des
adaptations il faut pouvoir faire le
point et en termes d'expertise on nos
salariés c'est très compliqué puisque il
faut acquérir une expertise sur des cas
particuliers qui vont se présenter pour
certains une fois une fois de temps en
temps donc on est en train de travailler
avec la CNAV pour voir si on pourrait
par exemple sur tout ce qui est
recouvrement des ateliers de pension
alimentaire
sous-traiter avec une caisse de
métropole parce qu'il faut savoir qu'en
métropole déjà si sectorisé enfin c'est
un rassemblé par la mutualisation alors
je vous dis pas que si pour une petite
population comme la nôtre c'est très
compliqué à mettre en place
donc on le fait mais c'est du c'est de
la gestion manuelle donc c'est très
compliqué
et
au delà de ça on a les problématiques
liées au tout ce qui est correspond aux
emplois en métropole il faut savoir que
quand en 2016 le CMG et la SF ont été
tendus à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon il
était prévu que la gestion du CMG soit
transitoire soit 31 décembre 2016 par la
CPS elle devait être prise par le
Pajemploi une année plus tard et puis il
y a eu une extension d'une année sur la
prise en charge CPS en attendant que le
Pajemploi puisse développer un outil de
gestion
puisque le problème qu'avait
le gestionnaire c'était que son outil
était développé on va dire dans le dur
et que les paramètres spécifiques de sa
pyrénité sont les taux de cotisations
les assiettes de cotisation différentes
du régime général ne pouvait donc pas
être modifié dans son outil ça supposait
un développement entier du même
applicatif en l'occurrence et pour le
coup
au final ça s'est terminé
un autre boudin pour nous puisqu'on
s'est retrouvés à pas développer un
outil de gestion parce que c'était
temporaire et à faire une gestion
manuelle au départ et finalement on
s'est retrouvé à garder la gestion sans
avoir l'outil et c'est très compliqué
pour nos équipes et donc on a eu un
échange avec le Pajemploi je profite de
l'occasion récemment qui nous disait que
ils allaient intégrer Mayotte avec des
paramètres particuliers du coup
dans les la période à venir et on se
disait qu'il y avait peut-être une
fenêtre pour nous pour faciliter du coup
les démarches des familles qui pourrait
se faire en ligne et
voilà quoi que les familles de
l'archipel puisse bénéficier de
l'abonnement de service en fait voilà
et plus simple pour nos équipes
personnellement c'est complexes
dont la deuxième question Stéphane par
rapport au lit avec l'État dont je passe
demanderais après à Sonia d'intervenir
parce que je peux constater c'est que
dans nos relations avec l'Éducation
nationale là on a on constate une
amélioration depuis l'avenue de la
rectrice de Caen et le fait aussi que le
président de les sollicités donc ça
permet de bouger les choses en tout cas
sur l'accompagnement des familles parce
qu'on tient ce qui est un service social
qui soit vraiment sur de la prévention
ou étant au niveau des familles que des
jeunes et aussi à décliner des
programmes nationaux et ça on a trouvé
que c'était vraiment une amélioration
pour nous après j'ai laissé passer par
les seniors mais il me semble que c'est
plus Sonia qui enfin il y a un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui relèveraient
de la transiter par l'ats
l'administration territoriale de la
santé qui est en fait
notre ARS local et on fait je pense que
c'est surtout Sonia qui met une
vigilance
législative pour aller réclamer voilà ce
qu'on peut obtenir parce qu'en fait la
démarche il me semble ne se fait pas
mais je parle sous le contrôle de Sonia
je sais pas si Sonia tu peux dire
quelques mots sur ce sujet
sur le sujet qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui je dirais que
je pense pas que le effectivement à
l'état est vraiment un rôle moteur on a
eu beaucoup de difficultés en fait à
impliquer et à mobiliser dans le projet
territorial l'enfant jeunesse qu'on a
signé en 2020
on a des difficultés à mobiliser les
partenaires que de l'état des services
des différents
ça repose encore essentiellement sur la
collectivité territoriale et la CPS et
donc cette constat on est des tous de
très petites équipes en immobilisé sur
plein de sujets à la fois et c'était
parfait île de voilà de d'avancer tous
ensemble au même risque avec le même
objectif donc ça revient quand on disait
tout à l'heure sur la nécessaire
coordination et l'adoption d'une
politique vraiment territoriale dans ce
champ quoi
d'accord merci est-ce que vous avez
d'autres questions de votre côté
Stéphane
regarde mes collègues mais visiblement
ce n'est pas le cas donc je ne vois pas
non plus
je vérifie simplement victoire on te
voit maintenant les convives
à tout ce qui se dit donc merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président et mesdames vous
étiez que des dames donc je vous
remercie pour l'intégralité de ce que
vous avez dit
peu de questions parce que j'étais
interpellée quand même par le fait qu'il
y ait eu une absentéisme pour un enfant
par exemple vous allez constater que
pendant 90 jours on a fait 400 on avait
90 demi-journée pardon c'est 90 minutes
c'est important donc alors je voudrais
savoir si vous êtes en relation avec les
associations de parents d'élèves du
territoire est-ce que vous avez des
projets communs parce que là vous allez
citer un certain nombre d'associations
qui sont sur le territoire mais aussi en
hexagone en fait vous dites la métropole
donc j'aimerais savoir si au niveau
localisation de parents d'élèves
pour sollicite également la deuxième
question est-ce que vous bénéficiez des
fléchés dans le cadre du plan pour voter
j'ai gouvernement l'autre c'est l'autre
question c'est les contrats locaux à
parentalité d'aide à la scolarité
alors est-ce que vous avez des demandes
de sens est-ce que vous avez des
projet si on fait sens et ma toute
dernière question c'est la question de
la restauration scolaire alors bon je
sais que c'est exceptionnel c'est la
première fois que j'entends qu'il n'y a
pas de restauration
parce qu'il y avait pas suffisamment de
de besoin de se faisait pas sentir ou
est-ce que c'est un choix de la
collectivité est-ce que vous pouvez
m'éclairer sur ces questions là je vous
remercie d'accord merci alors sur les
associations de parents d'élèves en fait
les contacts que l'on a avec eux c'est
c'est au travers des différentes
instances comme la CDAPH ne font pas
vraiment remonter leurs besoins leur
non j'ai pas enfin voilà ça de temps en
temps si bon quand il y a des des
situations
des situations un petit peu difficiles
mais je pense que il le gère avec
l'Éducation nationale pour revenir sur
l'absentéisme
l'association l'appel au niveau des
écoles c'est vrai que dans le privé ils
sont assez demandeurs d'événements
on parle pas au niveau du décrochage
scolaire
ils sont assez s'il y a des intervenants
des cafés des parents et ils sont très
insoumis ils sont très réactifs à
transmettre l'information quand il y a
des événements
c'est le dernier café que j'avais pu
organiser l'année dernière ils avaient
très très vite réagi à envoyer dans le
palier de liaison de tous les enfants
diffusés par mail aux parents donc le
public un peu moins noté mais en tout
cas le privé au niveau de l'impact
et sur la santé comme je l'expliquais
tout à l'heure il y a quand même des
choses qui sont en train de se mettre en
place et entre autres
des formations à distance par le
rectorat de Normandie pour impulser un
petit peu une
une dynamique sur les informations
préoccupantes sur comment on peut gérer
et voilà donc c'est quelque chose qu'on
a qui est en train de se faire donc on
va voir là
dans les 6 prochains mois s'il y a
vraiment une amélioration de ce côté là
mais on a quand même bien expliqué que
c'était plus accep d'avoir 90 de mes
journées d'absence avant de avant de le
signaler voilà ou de sauter là on est
vraiment une une vigilance de ce côté là
et je dirais quand même peut-être un peu
de pression aussi quand même donc sur
les crédits de pauvreté c'est aide Sonia
tu peux qu'il maîtrise
oui donc on a signé effectivement une
convention de lutte contre la pauvreté
avec l'État il y a quelques années donc
qui est arrivé à échéance on n'a pas
encore renégocié dans le cas du Pacte
des solidarités mais c'est effectivement
un axe qu'on aurait on souhaiterait
développer pour les années à venir c'est
vrai que l'ancien l'ancienne convention
lutte contre la pauvreté c'est très axé
sur sur l'accompagnement des
bénéficiaires du RSA et puis voilà sur
des problématiques qui touchaient pas la
parentalité et à cette question mais
c'est vrai que on aimerait vraiment
orienter nos prochaines actions sur sur
ce domaine et de l'élargir parce que là
cette convention avait été signée
exclusivement avec la collectivité dans
un premier temps donc pour pouvoir y
associer vraiment les municipalités
merci Sonia sur les contrats locaux de
ce scolarité la prestation existe mais
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de porteurs
de projets ou associative pour mener à
bien
l'accompagnement de voir et puis toute
tout l'accompagnement global qu'on
souhaiterait développer auprès des
enfants et des jeunes on a un petit
espoir voilà on a une nouvelle
association qui s'appelle
Labège qui vient d'ouvrir un espace
jeune
d'ouvrir son espace jeune donc là aussi
largement appuyé par la collectivité
territoriale et la CPS au travers du bah
oui du projet territorial en France
jeunesse et voilà donc
ils évoluent progressivement ils vont
déjà commencer sur l'accueil des 14 17
déployer des actions comme des chantiers
jeunes ou des actions qui sont pensés et
réalisées par les jeunes mais je sais
que l'association a aussi ça en tête de
pouvoir développer l'accompagnement aux
devoirs et des jeunes après après
l'école quoi et mes pensées quelque
chose qui pourrait potentiellement
arriver dans quelques années mais le
projet il est pas là de manière
immédiate en tout cas
et sinon sur la partie restauration
scolaire nous on rentrera pas seulement
pourquoi il y a pas de restauration
scolaire mise en place tout simplement
on a été sollicité sur la question
suite au projet de d'ouverture
d'internat à la prochaine rentrée avec
du coup évidemment des repas pour les
présidents
à savoir que juste pour information que
le la prestation qui existe en outre-mer
la part n'est pas étendue à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
après simplement c'est pas forcément
ce qui serait plus opportun ou le plus
adapté je pense que si toutefois il y
avait une volonté de développement de
restauration collective il y a une
réflexion à mener globale en amont parce
que les montants correspondant par
rapport au coûts les reports qui me sont
avancés par l'Éducation nationale sont
complètement déconnectés donc voilà
bon voilà on a pris la tâche de la CNAV
pour comprendre le fonctionnement de la
prestation les modalités pour y élargir
ça suppose une modification législatives
est-ce que ça vaut le coup de le faire
on en est pas certain on vu des montants
correspondants puisqu'en terme de profil
en correspondrait davantage au profil
des Outre-mer hors Mayotte et ses
maillots qui alimentent les plus
importants qui restent malgré tout des
montants très peu élevés sur le coup
d'un repas si vous avez été avancé à 21
euros par l'Éducation nationale
mais par rapport à la restauration
scolaire donc ce dont Sylvie parlait
tout à l'heure c'est qu'il y a un projet
enfin il y a un internat pour les jeunes
de Miquelon c'est à peu près entre 20 et
25 et élèves qui sont concernés tous les
ans donc pour venir sur la sur
Saint-Pierre poursuivre leur scolarité
de la seconde à la terminale
parce que ça devenait très compliqué de
trouver des familles d'accueil et donc
l'éducation nationale s'est engagée avec
l'hôpital et on est sur une prise en
charge à une cinquantaine d'euros par
jour c'est-à-dire 21 euros pour le repas
du midi 21 euros en gros pour le repas
du soir et en gros je pose une dizaine
d'euros pour le goûter le petit-déjeuner
donc inutile de vous dire comme c'est
quand même très compliqué de trouver des
financements donc ça c'est une chose la
deuxième c'est plus le besoin de
comptines chez les chez les plus jeunes
en tout cas qui sont beaucoup moins
autonome ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
dans l'archipel il y a des familles qui
récupèrent
les enfants à midi et qui leur dépose
qui doivent leur déposer vers une heure
à l'école en période hivernale ça reste
compliqué parce que c'est vite vite il
faut que tu t'habilles vite vite voilà
et on a le sentiment nous en tout cas en
tant que plusieurs mamans on leur
apporter que elle n'avait pas vraiment
l'impression que ce temps que l'on
pensait être un temps privilégié pour
les échanges entre midi et une heure et
demie était plutôt un temps ou en
bouscule les enfants et c'est bien sûr
arriver avec le travail féminin et il y
a peut-être un peu de de je dirais de
réticence à se dire qu'il faut mettre en
place une une coquine scolaire et puis
récupérer son enfant plus tôt et plus
détendu donc il y a une tentative qui
s'est fait dans l'enseignement privé qui
est ici quand même aussi important sinon
plus que l'enseignement public au niveau
en tout cas du maternel primaire et
collège puisque la partie la partie
lycée uniquement dans l'enseignement
public donc qui était de proposer je
commence un peu des boîtes à lunch comme
ça se fait au Canada après la difficulté
que l'on rencontre c'est qu'on est tout
petit il faut vraiment une enquête pour
voir combien de familles seraient
intéressés et c'est surtout que les les
établissements scolaires qui sont qui
sont anciens n'ont pas de cuisine donc
quelles solutions on peut on peut porter
pour répondre aux familles il y a tout
un travail qui effectivement serait
intéressant à amener et c'est vrai que
les familles sont de plus en plus de
monde en effet évoque c'est plus
attentif et c'est fait dans le dans le
speed et évoque très souvent plus la
séparation des parents donc les livres
enfin les cartables faut changer les
livres c'est toute une gestion familiale
même si un peu de distance finalement ça
devient complexe et l'idée de la boîte à
lunch du privé donc faut quand même que
les parents importent le repas de
l'enfant mais en effet ça fonctionne
très bien donc c'est une surveillance en
fait qui est voilà c'est pas encore
cantine ou le le parent n'a pas géré et
du coup c'est un repas qui est unique
pour tous les enfants mais ceci dit
c'est une avancée et je pense qu'il est
fortement apprécié en effet voilà sur le
sujet je sais pas si vous avez d'autres
questions
harcèlement vous avez parlé de
harcèlement mais quels sont les mesures
que vous avez mises en place
s'il vous plaît merci
sur le harcèlement c'est en fait
l'éducation nationale on l'a on a évoqué
les choses lors du dernier comité de
prévention de la délinquance où je
dirais que c'est pas une instance que je
chéris particulièrement parce que je
mais au moins la dernière fois quand on
y est allé ça a permis d'aborder le
problème de du harcèlement milieu
scolaire parce que nous le retour qu'on
avait nos travailleurs sociaux vu qu'il
y a pas de de service social encore au
niveau de l'éducation nationale c'est
que ces retours il y avait un réel
problème et donc qui était un peu lié
quand même localement par l'Éducation
nationale
bon on se demandait s'il avait vraiment
les mêmes remontées que nous et en fait
là la réponse c'est vraiment de mettre
en place le programme de décliner le
plus rapidement possible avec le
rectorat de Caen de former le programme
national qui s'appelle le programme
phare qui a un problème qui a un
programme qui est très intéressant qui
est qui comprend à la fois la formation
des enseignants mais aussi de la
formation des jeunes en tant que témoin
et qui aussi cible le climat scolaire
donc c'est quelque chose qui donne de
bons résultats en métropole ça a été
rendu c'était expérimental sur les deux
trois dernières années en métropole dans
certaines régions et ça a été rendu
obligatoire en métropole depuis la
rentrée de septembre 2022 et ça n'avait
pas été décliné ici donc c'est une chose
dans nos échanges avec le rectorat que
l'on a obtenu et on espère bien que ça
va être mis en place c'est qu'il y a de
nouvelles approches avec une formation
des enseignants une prise en charge qui
qui nous semblait un peu banalisée
jusqu'ici
comprennent vraiment un bras de corps ce
sujet qui
en fait de faire de notre archip un
territoire de bien-être et effectivement
le bien-être à l'école est quelque chose
d'incontournable pour nous de
prioritaires je sais pas si vous me
rejoignez mesdames vous avez une volonté
de la part de l'équipe éducative et de
la vie scolaire ils avaient gagné un
projet national d'ailleurs avec un spot
vidéo qui avait été réalisé par les
jeunes sur le harcèlement quand elle
était diffusé dans tous les lycées de
Mégal et outre-mer et c'est vrai que ça
avait été mené il y a quatre ans
maintenant vous savez bien fonctionné
c'était une volonté de l'équipe vie
scolaire donc en fait ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'il y a eu des il y a eu des
interventions il y a eu des actions
quand on dirait one shot comme ça et
qu'après tout retombe et en fait le
besoin est il y avait pas de continuité
dans l'action et avec ce programme fin
ce qu'on voit c'est que c'est une action
continue avec une veille qui est mise en
place avec des personnes qui sont
identifiées tant au niveau des
enseignants qu'au niveau des élèves et
on y va et ça commence dès le cours
préparatoire donc on y est
particulièrement vigilant sur
l'application et en incendie du côté que
du rectoratan c'était les priorités
aussi
merci merci pour ces précisions et je
laisse la parole maintenant si tu
Sénart
et les vélos et il y a un certain nombre
de recommandations parce que là il y a
pas que l'éducation nationale il y a
tous les acteurs qui doivent simplifier
dans cette démarche désolé monsieur le
Président
c'est qu'effectivement c'est aussi ce
qu'on a ce qu'on souhaite décliner avec
l'Éducation nationale quand on veut
travailler sur le développement des
compétences psychosociales des enfants
c'est de faire en sorte que tout ce qui
savent frais et les formations qui
seront données au sein d'éducation
nationale puis veste vous avez je vous
remercie d'ailleurs de m'interpoler sur
le sujet qui va être décliner tu sais
décliner dans le péril et l'extra
scolaire
merci donc cette fois-ci je peux laisser
la parole à Micheline Jacques en prix
qui est en présence merci Président
chers collègues Mylène je vous remercie
pour toutes ces informations très
éclairantes je me suis un petit peu
retrouvée dans vos explications puisque
je suis sénateur de Saint-Barthélémy
donc une toute petite île qui connaît un
certain nombre nous avons un certain
nombre de similitudes à cause de
l'insularité
juste une question
pratico pratique pour avoir été
enseignante et directrice d'école
pendant de nombreuses années le décalage
horaire avec le avec le rectorat de Caen
d'une part et
ont-ils aussi une culture des outre-mer
et une culture de l'insularité pour
pouvoir répondre à certaines
problématiques que vous rencontrez sur
sur votre territoire mais ma question
plus on va dire plus importante
s'attacherait à vous avez parlé des
de la naissance des accouchements thèmes
aussi chers à mon coeur puisque vous
avez la chance de pouvoir les bébés ont
la chance de pouvoir naître chez vous
alors que chez nous ce n'est pas le cas
j'aurais aimé savoir sur les grossesses
à risque donc dans les feuilles dans les
maires sont évacuées doivent partir je
présume à l'avance est-ce que la est-ce
que votre CPS prévoit des dispositifs
spécifiques pour accompagner ces
familles puisque je présume qu'il doit y
avoir un coût lié à
quelqu'un soit c'est pas la branche
famille en fait de la CPS qui qui met en
place le dispositif c'est la branche
maladie c'est un décret de 1991 qui
prévoit
d'une part quand
le médecin conseil que la la patiente
doivent être suivies
[Musique]
évidemment par la CPS et il y a des
indemnités
d'hébergement journalières qui sont
versés pour aider à subvenir aux frais
d'hébergement
du de la personne de la de la marque
future maman si elle n'est pas
hospitalisée et du papa en l'occurrence
et
donc notre service Action sociale peut
aussi venir en complément pour aider sur
toutes les démarches
préalable au départ
sociale parce qu'il y a des raisons sur
Madame métropole en général c'est sur
Rennes et que quand il y a eu la plupart
sont Canada mais bon il y a des
correspondants à Saint-Jean où en
métropole avec lesquels notre service
intervenir et pour venir en soutien donc
voilà les principales
à le dispositif tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui pour compléter les propos de
ma collègue on a créé depuis deux ans
aussi parce que bon comme on le sait
leur CPAS collabranche maladie famille
et vieillesse de la sécurité sociale et
du coup à l'image des parcours
attentionnés que en cas pu créer
l'assurance maladie depuis quelques
années donc on s'est inspiré et on a
créé un parcours d'essence parentalité
donc en fait on a créé une petite
mallette avec les différents services de
la CPS qui interviennent dans la
grossesse ou la naissance puisque avant
les informations étaient envoyées de
manière assez disparate et l'idée
c'était de coordonner ce qu'on pouvait
faire avec nos services en court terme
donc on a créé un parcours attentionné
avec une mallette ma paternité ou à
l'intérieur donc une fois la déclaration
de grossesse déposée à l'accueil de la
CPS la maman ou les parents se voient
remettre cette manette et à l'intérieur
de cette manette qui sont personnalisés
jusqu'au date de congé maternité etc on
a tout un tas d'informations au cas où
la maman est besoin d'être évacuée
au Canada ou en métropole avec voilà les
démarches
administratives logistique les
différents points que ma collègue sylvie
a pu soulever avant notamment sur les
Inde les indemnisations quand on est
évacué soit sur Saint-Jean Terre-Neuve
ou sur un métropole donc on essaye
vraiment que les familles puissent avoir
de manière assez anticipée l'ensemble
des informations pour être en capacité
de se préparer alors on est jamais prêt
mais d'avoir au moins les informations
en cas de départ anticiper sur des
soucis de santé de la mer ou de l'enfant
alors vous me confirmez bien que c'est
un dispositif propre à la CPS de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon oui oui tout à
fait c'est un décret spécifique qui date
de 1991 et qui ne concerne que la CPAS
de saint-pierre-du-cloud
je vous remercie infiniment
puisque nous sommes je suis un peu seul
il faut bien le dire en cette fin de
journée mais ça ne m'intimide absolument
pas en tout cas merci mille fois de vos
apports et des précisions pourrez et que
vous jugerez utile par écrit surtout
c'est à dire qu'on a une trame de
question qui vous a été adressée si vous
avez des supports qui viennent étayer ou
sur lesquels vous souhaiteriez apporter
un éclairage complémentaire au
rapporteur n'hésitez surtout pas et en
tout cas milles merci de votre
disponibilités de cette audition bonne
fin de journée à toutes et à tous merci
au revoir
[Musique]
au
revoir